ferienwohnungs ärger das ist halt immer
eine tolle sache wenn man sich eine
ferienwohnung gemietet und da kann man
mit mehreren personen dort auch
übernachten und spart auch ein bisschen
aber wenn das dann so nicht so richtig
klappt dann ist das natürlich auch sehr
ärgerlich und torben thiele aus
bremerhaven ist uns jetzt zugeschaltet
und sie haben da ganz große probleme
gehabt was ist da passiert
oh ja wir hatten anfang januar ein
ferienhaus oder soll
für quasi neun personen sechs sterne auf
das haus alles bezahlt und alles schön
auch im urlaub gefreut jetzt eine woche
vor urlaubsantritt quasi haben wir die
nachricht gekriegt dass nur was hole das
haus andersweitig verbucht hatte ein
fehler unterlaufen ist was ihr zugegeben
haben paar tage vorher haben wir ein
anderes gleichwertiges objekt angeboten
bekommen
ihr kommt natürlich keine bilder nichts
sehen wir mussten schnell entscheiden
angesagt ja machen mussten aber 260 euro
oder auf bezahlen aber auch gesagt bevor
der urlaub vorbei ist fahren wir hin und
machen das
ankunft waren so bekamen wir ein das
grundstück komplett vorbilder
zwei personen konnten den block nicht
antreten weil es nur für sechs personen
war das aus das haus war eine baustelle
da waren nichts was wir vorher hatten
entweder fehlen sehr
es war nichts da keine sauna nichts 45
kilometer bis zum nächsten vernünftigen
einkaufsladen eigene stärke und ja die
wollen dann kommt er ins gesicht gezogen
im endeffekt sollen wir jetzt sogar
stornogebühren bezahlen für den fehler
den rollstuhl verbockt hat
ja absolut auch ein irrer fall vor allem
der urlaub ist ja auch wirklich dahin
und wir haben auch fotos vorbereitet die
diese neue ferienwohnungen zeigen dann
möchte man in wahrheit wirklich kein
urlaub verbringen das ist jetzt hier das
wohnzimmer sie haben luxus gebucht aber
kriegen jetzt hier allenfalls mittelmaß
da muss ich mal an canon fenster zu
nehmen das ist wirklich eine frechheit
oder das ist das ist wirklich eine
vertragliche frechheit
wir haben ja einen reisevertrag
geschlossen zu bestimmten bedingungen
und das muss eben auch geliefert werden
und wenn da teile eben nicht geliefert
werden also wenn wir diesen zustand
sehen dann ist das natürlich ein mangel
allein die lage ist ja schon ein mangel
und das eben das eben keine achter
wohnung ist sondern 6 ab wohnung war ist
und wenn wir die fotos sehen
beispielsweise dann muss man klar sagen
das ist absolut nicht in ordnung hat mit
luxus überhaupt nichts zu tun und da
würde ich sogar so weit gehen wenn man
das so sieht dass man sagt ich möchte
den gesamten reisepreis zurück haben
plus schmerzensgeld denn es gibt ja so
ein schmerzensgeldanspruch für
entgangene urlaubsfreuden
und da steht ausdrücklich im gesetz das
ist ganz interessant da bekommt man den
reisepreis zurück und in gleicher höhe
ein schmerzensgeldanspruch weil man hat
ja diesen der diesen urlaub der ja der
erholung dienen soll den hat man ja
einsetzen müssen und es total vergeigt
worden und hier immer natürlich auch ein
verschulden der überbuchung ist
natürlich ein verschulden des
unternehmens oder eines mitarbeiters
verschulden eines mitarbeiters wird dem
unternehmen zu gerechnet also
schadenersatz und schmerzensgeld